and for more on the Turkish referendum I
have with me Jim Austin eeeh
he's the co-chairman of the German a
Green Party welcome Jim was here to DW
TV now you're a German politician with
Turkish roots you were campaigning and
Cooling on Turks in Germany to vote no
in this referendum now we know a
majority has voted for yes you're
calling for serious consequences what do
you mean by that well first of all I
think it's important to see the frame
only 50 percent of those who could woods
in Turkey voted participated in the
election unlike in Turkey where almost
90 percent participated so if you have
that in mind if you have in mind that
people who have a German passport not
having a Turkish Passport could not vote
at all I think it looks a little bit
different but as you mentioned already
we have to look into integration
policies and discuss what has to be
changed so when you talk about serious
consequences what do you mean by that I
think if you live in this country if you
participate from democracy and support
the dictatorship in another country you
have to ask yourself whether you really
feel comfortable in this country and we
as German politicians have to ask
ourselves what went wrong in the last
decades and what do you think went wrong
because it has to be remembered that as
you mentioned a minority of those
eligible to vote in this referendum
voted but a majority of them voted in
favor of yes and they are living in a
democratic country but voting for what
is being viewed as an authoritarian
system absolutely I mean it was way too
late when my party in government finally
established birth rights in Germany it
was in the year 2000 it took us decades
that we finally said that children are
born in our country our children were
citizens by birth in our country have in
mind that that was posed at that time
from today's government from Angela
Merkel's party second problem religious
policies we have mosques that are under
the leadership of Richard type aired on
the Turkish president our lender
governments have to look into these
policies we can only accept religious
instruction in schools organized by
organizations which are independent from
Turkey that is another policy area that
has to be changed and a third field
would be education policies it is
working class children it is children of
immigrant families that are failing in
our mainstream school system that is
another issue that needs to be put on
the agenda so is this a failure of these
kind of policies in Germany which
explain why so many people of Turkish
origin feel alienated in Germany now
you're a politician here you are a part
of the mainstream but many Turks who
live here don't feel part of the
mainstream at all well again have in
mind that only a parts participated in
the elections so we should not blackmail
the huge majority of Turks that are
integrated some of them are movie makers
some of them are party leaders some of
them are taking responsibility in other
fields of this society so let's not
oversee that part but yes we also have
to see the other part which we tend to
oversee which is participating in
democracy enjoying democracy enjoying a
free market economy but at the same time
supporting in another country in which
they are not living in which they are
not paying taxes dictatorship and this
is also a debate in Turkey a lot of
people in Turkey called me and said to
me we don't understand this you know
they're not affected by what they're
voting for so my position would be if
you live in this country you should
integrate into this country you should
vote in this country and not in a
country in which you don't live and
talking about living in this country
Germany is holding national elections in
September what do you think this
referendum means will it play into the
German election in any way well I
already did part of the strategy of
other Aragon was to escalate the
situation between Europe and Turkey and
probably it helped him in the elections
in Turkey to use the national feelings
in Turkey because he needs allies it
needs enemies he needs enemies both
within the Turks society and outside in
particular in Europe so we have to look
through Turkish German election at
German Turkish relations I think the
military relationship has to stop we
have to take back our soldiers from in
Jurek and talking about integration
policies we have to look through the
whole area of integration policies I
would personally be in favor of a new
consensus in German politics regarding
integration it should be our national
that the hearts and the minds of people
of Turkish origin should focus on this
country it should be clear the solution
of our problems live within this country
and not in Turkey and finally and reef
Liam mr. Samir
what does this referendum result mean
for Turkish aspirations to be part of
the European Union at some point with a
president airline I don't see Turkey as
a member of the European Union that's
unthinkable I think of it and that's
because of the death penalty that he
wants to reenter because of the death
penalty nuts because of democracy that's
abuses of power that's because of human
rights violations that's because of the
comeback of torture I could name your
thousands of reasons there is no freedom
of expression in Turkey the current
Turkish leadership has nothing in common
with what we describe Western well the
use of well use of democracy Jim used
Amir co-chair of the German Green Party
thank you very much for talking to us
and coming into our studios on DW